كنا معك قبل قليل وتابعنا بشكل مباشر
العمليات الجاريه في جباليه وجباليا البلد
الياس بالفعل عبد القادر وهي ما زالت
متواصله لكن يبدو ان التركيز هذا اليوم
يطال ال الاحياء الشماليه لمدينه غزه وان
كان مخيم جباليا وجباليا البلد ايضا هي
مناطق ساخنه وتشهد اشتباكات مع الجيش
الاسرائيلي و بين الجيش الاسرائيلي
والمقاومه ال الفلسطينيه نحن نشاهد هنا
الاحياء الشماليه لمدينه غزه وهنالك قصف
يطال احياء ب بعينها تحديدا الشماليه منها
والمعارك عبد القادر ما زالت مستمره في
اكثر من موقع وفي اكثر من مكان حقيقه في
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه بيت حنون في
الشمال بيت لاهيه في الشمال تشهد اشتباكات
وهنالك قصف مت فعي وجوي مستمر كذلك جباليا
المخيم وجباليا البلد كما نشاهد هي تحت
القصف الاسرائيلي وكذلك الاحياء الشماليه
لمدينه غزه التي يبدو ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
كما قالت بياناته يوسع من عملياته
العسكريه في تلك الاحياء وهذا ما يفسر
الاعداد الكبيره ايضا من الجرحى والقتلى
في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي الجيش
الاسرائيلي اعلن قبل قليل في بيانه اليومي
عن اصابه
27 عسكريا اسرائيليا في معارك قطاع غزه اي
لكن بشكل تراكمي فيما اذا نظرنا الى
الايام الثلاثه او الاربعه الماضيه فان
اعداد الجنود الذين جرحوا واصيبوا في هذه
المعارك بشكل تراكمي عبد القادر وصل الى
نحو 200 جندي وضابط جريح وهذا عدد كبير
وهذا يدل على ان المعارك على اشدها وهي
كبيره ومتواصله هذا رغم ان ارقام الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما زالت بعيده كل البعد حتى عن
الارقام التي توردها وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه والتي كانت تحدثت في جلسه
خاصه في الكنيست قبل اسبوع عن ان عدد
الجرحى بين الضباط والجنود الاسرائيليين
الذين يتلقون الدعم
من وزاره الدفاع ومن قسم التاهيل او اعاده
التاهيل يصل الى 3000